the head of the un's atomic agency has
arrived at the russian-controlled
zafarisha nuclear power plant Rafael
Grossi is leading a team to inspect the
facility after the breach of the nearby
kahovka Dam last week the international
atomic energy agency is worried about
water levels used to cool the plant and
heavy fighting in the area meanwhile
Russian airstrikes hit the southern
Ukrainian city of Hassan overnight on
Thursday the attack destroyed an office
building residents say it's the first
time Rockets hit the center of the city
we're going to go live to Akiva Al
jazeer as Jonah Hall is standing by
we're going to talk about this visit by
Rafael Grossi and his team the trip the
trip has been delayed for a while what
are they going to be looking for
well it was delayed if you remember for
24 hours it was meant to happen on
Wednesday uh on Thursday pardon
um and was delayed because of travel
safety concerns Mr Grossi arrived at the
plant getting out of what looked like a
bulletproof car in full body armor and
that gives you a pretty clear sense of
where this place is located the nuclear
plant the biggest in Europe it is in
territory controlled by Russia since the
early stages of the war close to the
front lines frequently fighting close at
hand which has sparked fears for its
safety before a current though concerns
come from the breach of the kakovka dam
last week it's flood waters surging
South uh depleting the dam which had
been crucial for providing cooling
waters for the six reactors of the
zaparesia nuclear plant and its cooling
Reservoir now Mr Grossi is there to see
his own team the iaied iaea team
permanently situated at the plant and to
inspect the damage and assess the danger
for himself clearly any possibility of
an accident any significant damage there
could have catastrophic wider
consequences yeah we were talking
earlier about the um the attacks that
have been going on in Carson as well
what are you hearing about those
foreign
airstrikes broadly speaking keeping up a
pretty consistent Tempo at the moment
across the south and east of the country
but unusual that airstrikes come into
harshon City Ukraine's military command
talking about long-range bombers and
su-35 uh Jets over the Black Sea
launching missiles at Kershaw city which
is you say they of course damage to
civilian infrastructure no word on
significant injuries normally cash on
city tends to get hit by artillery
strikes from the east side of the river
this is pretty unusual and missiles
launched in the same attack at Mikko
live a bit further south but Port
infrastructure there and at the black
seaport city of Odessa causing only
limited damage there separately uh
cruise missiles fired from the Caspian
Sea hit the Central City of crevy reef
for the second time in three days again
not deadly one injury reported there but
the ukrainians saying the Russians now
seem to be targeting Supply Depots not
ammunition and weapon so much as
consumable supplies what they describe
as Logistics support for the front lines
Jonah thank you very much indeed that's
Jonah Hall bringing us up to date from
Kiev